all right
hop breath the verse welcome back to hot
breath the show where you learn comedy
from the pros
i am your host comedian joel byers and
we are all
here at hop breath on a mission to
cultivate the next generation
of great comics and this guest today is
without a doubt
part of that generation he started
comedy at the age of 18
and only eight years in to his career he
has already gone viral
on social media with his own character
sonny bo that has over 10 million views
and now
he is releasing a comedy special
only eight years in this cat is
definitely on the fast track so we're so
excited to have him here
on hot breath so welcome to the hot
breath verse
the one and only lewis belt everyone
show louis some love what's up with it
yeah yeah
yeah there's a clapping sound effect
going on we got you
yeah love us what's up with y'all how
y'all doing my man
welcome aboard dude it's it's so cool to
have you on here
especially at this point in your career
it's gotta it's gotta be gratifying to
be feeling this like
momentum because i mean you've been
grinding but to actually
a lot of comics we grind with our heads
down but to actually seeing it pay off
that's got to really be gratifying
yeah you know i mean the world to a
standard comic you know i feel like i
didn't got
famous and popular for all the that
you know that helps me
with my standard but it haven't been my
stand-up
yeah because i really you know stand up
don't get a lot of attention
it got to be something major for people
to just tune into standard comedy
so you know for it to be stand-up comedy
you know
this is really what i ask for type yeah
that's what's cool in seeing your other
interviews is how you're
very intentional about i'm not an
instagram comic i'm a stand-up first
like you're very intentional about
making sure people know that you're a
stand-up first
yeah for real because you know any
stand-up comedian can relate to it like
you know like
doing open mics and not having a fan
base and being in the chitlin circus
from
you know hollywood and even
growing up and like you know being in
the bay area starting my comedy career
in oakland in the bay area
just like it's not even a comedy scene
really you know what i'm saying so it's
like
i don't forget those days and i'm not
too far removed from that you know
for me to practice i still go to the
open mic i still practice any small room
so
you know that's something i really take
pride in you know
yeah that's something i definitely want
to get into social media and building a
following there but
i think if it's more valuable is being
able to build a following where you are
on a local level and really cultivate
like a grassroots fan base that becomes
your foundation
and you you've done that in oakland like
what uh how
how what kind of tips do you have for
comics and whatever scene they're in
like you said oakland doesn't even have
really much of a scene
compared to like in la or new york how
um how how can comics build like a local
following like you have
um cater to what's around you so like
for me
like i always took it from you know
getting taking a city by city because
the bay area is city you you know you
got
so many cities in one area so i'm kind
of like i'm doing everything to cater to
every city
but bringing it back to a foundation and
that is
oakland so once i felt like once i
grabbed everybody's attention
in the bay area then i couldn't i can't
expand
you know yeah so you know you start from
the ground up you know so
um i come from a uh the bay area is real
big on hip hop
independence and um athletes we got you
know we got major athletes so
you know i ran with doing stuff with mr
fab and doing stuff with
um just all the the hottest rappers in
the bay area
and and um doing stuff with the athletes
you know
like marshawn lynch you know marcus
peterson
you know just using all my resources
locally to the point where it's like
by time it it grows and grows
it becomes bigger than my area type
thing will you make it sound like you
just lived next door to marshawn lynch
and you're like hey let's collab
how do you connect with us how do you
connect with
how do you connect with those people in
your city you you gotta you
you gotta um you gotta build it from the
ground up like
you gotta make it to the point like um
you gotta
you gotta you gotta become important to
be important to other
important people you see what i'm saying
so the social media
platform that helped me because my skits
with sunnyball
and myself my character sonic bow like
i created like a a brand
and a coat of people that like my
content
you know what i'm saying so it brought
awareness to people that have their own
platform and then
you make it to the point it's like once
you built your own brand or your own
lane
you can collab with others oh you almost
have to have something to collab with
before you try to collab with someone
yeah people off the journal will try to
come off like looking for people that's
hot it's like no you got to get hot
first and then people that's hot
at work with you you know yeah and
that's that's something we talked we had
desi banks on here
talking about his first viral video was
him doing like
how a-town guys sound and he i don't
know if he a-town guys i don't think he
said it like that
but yeah atlanta but yeah like
he played into the atlanta like atlanta
scene in the city and kept it local like
you do with your character sonny bow
it's very
oakland that they exactly
check it out you know and then everybody
thought it was hella funny so i kept
doing it over and over and over again
but
when i was doing that i wasn't standing
like i was a stand-up comedy before i
did the skit
so it's kind of like that was a break i
was looking for
you know so by the time i did the skit
more people start cutting my shows my
fan base
i i knew it was working because my shows
was getting bigger
uh-huh and i didn't know it was like a
bay area
celebrity by the time me and marshawn
link
okay yeah see that's yeah that's where
it all started with
the the sketch and then you started to
build a buzz from that
yeah i had a big big buck by the time me
and marshawn
uh did business on like uh on a part
like you know like a skit yeah that was
like
damn near like the the peak like on
something like i can't get no higher
than this
like if i did it with marshawn then i'd
i didn't have my run with
sunnyvale
yeah i mean he's a he's yeah he's a
legend especially in the bay area
so i'm thinking it seems like comics
wherever they're based
because we have comics all over the
world like australia the uk
ireland um even lincoln nebraska not to
name all the big cities but it's like
almost
even a comic in lincoln nebraska it's
like hey
do something locally based and really
build something doing it do references
only they get in the sketch and things
like that and just build something for
your town
and that seems to be a great way to
spark online momentum that you can then
build on
yeah exactly like like with anything you
know you start from that
you start with the people that's close
and you know when she's taken by city by
city
like i was doing stuff that was so local
and i was catering so much to the bay
area
to the point where i started it it
started um
it started like it became
it became like it wasn't helped me at
some point because people from a grand
scale
couldn't relate because it was so local
you know and that's the advantage that
people like
a desi banks or are dcm flyer whoever
these people is in other
cities like they're from atlanta like
atlanta is popping popping like
like they got the migos they got future
they got
so if you if you get atlanta attention
you're going to be
bigger versus like the bay area it's
like it's so far you can go like the bay
area is not a place
um right now or when i was doing it at
the time
it wasn't like marshawn lynch was the
only person that was really on that
national scale that people can
uh identify my character with uh-huh
gotcha you know what i'm saying like oh
he might be acting like marshawn lynch
you know all right okay yeah so then
south university viewing the south is
kind of like
like if you're acting like a down south
character
all these people can relate uh memphis
north carolina south carolina
you know florida like a southern accent
is bigger than
a bay area accent yeah so i would just
only bare your fames for like
three years straight like a local
celebrity like i was desi banks to
debate
you know forever until i just expanded
my
my my content yeah so how how do you get
out of that bubble
uh going against the grain like i
honestly had to go against the grain
with my content where it's like people
was asking for me to be
sonny both and the only way i had to
only where i got out of stop being sonny
book is
um to i made it like sunnyvale went to
jail
ah well i kind of like i put my
character in jail
and it's like i have so many followers
to the point it's like all right
like um sonic bow and jail so you only
get that you're tuning in to louis bell
only now
that's smart yeah so it's like i made a
movement it's like free sunnyvale but
sonny for like
eight months to the point where people
forgot about sunnyvale uh-huh
and as soon as i stopped doing sunnyvale
mtv mtv
reached out to me and was like do you
want to be on are you the one
because they thought lewis belt was
funny oh
that was very clever man very savvy
there
yeah so i had to go against the grain i
had to go i had to deal with a lot of
comments like
uh louis bell i want to see sonny
bow like i had to
swallow that and be like you know
well well for a minute uh even dc young
fly got caught in this
um lane of roasting and they're like we
only want
we only want to watch it if he's
roasting and things like that and he had
to work himself out of that lane as well
and it's
worked out clearly and uh it's working
out for you too so there's definitely
something to that
yeah and i felt comfortable with doing
it because i always had stand-up comedy
yeah you know so it's like lewis belt
is the person they always paid to see
like even when sunnyvale was popping
those three years
when i was doing shows people coming to
see louis bell
yeah so it's like once once um
i i was kind of like promoting louis
bell and standing up the whole time
and and sonny bo like this internet
character
so that's like once i put sonic bowl up
it's like now you just only seen louis
bell at the shows and on social media
yeah a lot of a lot of us social media
cats if they find a character
they're that character and they get
stuck in it
yeah that's dangerous you're stuck
you're stuck that's why i had to
separate my page like my my social media
page is little do too much
but sonibo had its own social media page
the real sunny people so it's like
you know that's smart yeah you got to be
like i'm i'm competing with myself at
this point
what kind of social media tips do you
have for for comics
uh how they that is something comics
always ask is like oh i want
i want more followers i want you know i
want i want the heat or i want to go
viral like what kind of tips do you have
for comics when it comes to this social
media hustle
i feel like social media has to be
it has to be super super super creative
or it has to be extremely ignorant to
get some attention
on social media it's no other way like
you know and
i feel like uh the tips i would give a
comic would be like
do something that everybody's not doing
i feel like people try to go viral with
trying to follow a trend
and that only makes the person that
started the trend bigger
the only way to go for all social media
is to create a trend create your own way
and make people follow that
yeah and i think it's important to keep
creating
like yeah don't put all your eggs in one
basket on oh this is the thing i'm
spending
36 hours making this video it's like put
out a bunch of stuff
and see what sticks and start building
on that momentum
yeah like before i found before i
started doing sunnybrook i was just
doing all
type of videos where it's just like i
try to do a split video
roasting you know i try to do uh
just like ranting like you know like
yeah because
i only reason i started doing it because
i started seeing it work for others like
i'm
i'm i'm a stand-up comedian and i'm on
stage every day
and i'm watching just hilarious dc young
fly and they're getting just mega famous
and they don't perform
at the time so it's like i'm like all
right let me try to do with
they doing in my you know so i i
found my own niche
from just trying so many things you know
yes
keep trying it's kind of like trying a
new joke it's like you may write 20 and
only one of them you end up keeping
same thing with content i'd say exactly
it's just like a joke and then it's like
once you find that bit
where it's like oh people laughing at
that keep building that bit keep
adding to it to it so you know social
media i found that thing and it's like
i'm running with it yeah i find it i
struggle with consistency man like i
like sometimes i'm just like what is the
point or i'll scroll through my
phone just looking at my photo album
like well what do i even post like i get
caught almost in like overthinking it
maybe
yeah because you're thinking that from a
comic standpoint you know what i'm
saying because
a comic can't just say anything
like you just can't like comics think
really hard that's why it's
hard to do stand-up comedy because you
got to know where you're going with it
all the time
you feel me versus the internet you
don't
have to be going nowhere with it it
could just be a video just
it's not that damn jeans it's just
really like
yeah you gotta have a
attitude that's why a lot of
uh that's why a lot of social media
comedians are horrible on stage because
you can't go on stage and be like
it i'm gonna let it go like nah
like nah you need to think this through
you can't you can't redo this set like
right yeah because in your early days
you started with freestyling and you
realized oh i better i better get some
jokes in here
yeah you can really freestyle
the phone because you can just delete it
right
what is like what is i always ask comics
on here this question like what is
your worst like bomb or your worst booze
story from that those early days
um i feel like the worst
show i had
it wasn't from the fans standpoint it
was from a comedian
like it was like a local dude it was
like a local comedian i'm
young at the time having confidence
because i'm just thinking i'm just cool
this ain't got to do with comedy i'm
just the you get in my head
so it's like i did a show and i
performed and
a comedian was kind of like i would say
he was trying to heckle me he was
helping me
um and i didn't know how to handle it
because i'm like
i don't know at the time like
like i know you can roast the crowd but
i'm like do you
want a comedian heckle you like i'm
trying to perform for the fans
so basically like it came down to the
comedian heck of me he talking
then i'm like i'm roasting him so we
getting a pro session it's not about
now it's not a show anymore so it got to
the point where i told the community all
right come on stage let's have a roast
session the comedian
i gave him the mic and i went back and
forth with the mic and we wanted
we had a row session and i just felt
like
like i held my own but it was like i
the worst show i had is because i let
somebody control my set
it's like how did he end up i was like
that would have never happened if i had
experience
like i had to roast him and be like shut
your ass up you wish you was on stage
and then it went back to my center
catering to the crowd i kind of let him
take me out of my
my my uh set anyway it went bad because
i didn't get like no it wasn't like hey
my name is lewis bell and i get to walk
off stage you're just like the rope
session ending it's like i'm off state
like it was stupid like all right bet i
guess
all right cool yeah it felt
like a bomb for the crowd because i
didn't cater to the crowd
yeah were you headlining this show no
this was like open mic days open mic
days it was like a showcase in oakland
you know it wasn't nothing big it was
just some local
yeah do you still know this comic
um yeah i i never forget his name but
you know
because you know you had those moments
like you know certain you'll never
forget but you know
that's why i kind of be like you know
yeah myself a certain way like i told
you i should have left me to
loan to
try to be friends with me ah you wasn't
with me shooting in the gym
that's what it is yeah exactly like he
was praying on my downfall
yeah like i remember that day like the
comedian he tried to like on me he
was an older dude he'd been doing comedy
for years yeah
just like it was like he was like um he
was like yeah take some notes and i'm
and he gave me his uh his comedian cards
like yeah i could put you on one day
and it's like like he tried to flex on
me that day and it's like now look at
him like
i could really put him on and right now
yeah i heard you say in a quote that you
know don't try to compete with each
other try to eat with each other and
that's really stuck with me
exactly you know i'm saying people
people like
try to compete with each other too much
and it up what they got going on
i learned that from you know people
trying to compete with me and i'm like
i'm not gonna do that because i know how
that gets you sometimes
you can be above a comedian they surpass
right
over you and then you look like the dumb
and you
you legit never know who is going to be
who like
this guy you're at an open mic with six
months in
and six years he may be booking the
hottest show in the city like you
honestly you never know
yeah yeah and i feel like that's the
part that a lot of social
comedians social media comedians don't
get to experience because
you know you cut as soon as you start
going outside you already famous
you already popping you know what i'm
saying so it's like
i carry myself different from because
like like for the just for last show
like
i worked eight years for that show like
i i didn't get selected at that like
like i'm like wow like i'm finally
selected you know it's not like i don't
know like
oh what is just for laughs oh okay how
much the budget okay i'm gonna do it
like
no like i'm taking this real
seriously
of course yeah and the same thing with
like your comedy special it's like
something you were ready for
you know yes yeah sometimes
comics like we we want to microwave our
success and it's like i
i've heard several times on this show
like interviewing over 300 comics it is
hey
you can be seen too early but you can't
be seen too late so just focus on
getting funny
that's a good game i ain't heard that
one yeah that's facts
right there too yeah yeah we actually
have a question coming in from
um sean harper here asking
yeah this is a this is a good one about
posting stuff online he's like what is
your opinion on putting material online
that you're not ready to retire
so like yeah i guess posting your stand
up online
what's uh what's your opinion on that
for someone for like a newer comic is
what it's sounding like here
that that's a that's a great question
because um that was the
that was something that uh that's a
great question because i had to figure
that out
for myself um i feel like if you got the
joke polished already
i feel like you should release it
because if you don't have like a
commonly special coming up and you're
trying to get exposure
you got to put yourself out there
because nowadays people are not just
grab it like
you know like back in the day you used
to like work material up and be
like one day i'm gonna get on dev comedy
gmr i'm gonna say this a comic view or
hbo special it's not happening like that
no more like
if you got a joke that's polished put it
on youtube and they might discuss the
fans might discover you and then that
might get you
to a platform where it's like hey this
person's funny let's put them on this
show
so i recommend nobody don't hold no
material if
unless you got a strategic plan like i'm
working on this set for netflix i'm
working
but you know yeah and it's i would say
post something you can be proud of
though like
um something you would want people to
see that you're not looking back in two
years and you're like oh man i was
shooting that on an android on an open
mic in front of four people
it's like i don't know if i want that
out there type deal yeah but
maybe that's my opinion but but at the
same time
you can have post that and then if if
you upload it yourself
you can always be able to take it down
that's true
that is true yeah say if you get popping
you want to show people your growth so
you can be like
all right i got this clip for you when i
was at an open mic in front of four
people and i worked at this joke
you want to do the now and later yeah
yeah yeah
you want you want your people to see you
struggle so when you get to the next
level they appreciate like no i
like i've been supporting you you know
that's yeah that's that's true
actually yeah that i need to make some
of my old youtube videos on private now
i guess now i got to stop hiding that
stuff yeah
yeah i had i had to make a lot of stuff
private
when i posted it because i'm like oh i'm
not on that level no more
like oh yeah oh yeah uh he he followed
up here with
about uh live shows actually saying
um say this one's in a
different uh i'm in the weird space
where i'm hosting frequently and
featuring probably a little prematurely
so i was just wondering
a if i should hold off on emailing
bookers in search of feature work
and b is it even worth contacting out of
clubs
out of town clubs for host work
is it worth contacting comedy clubs to
host out of town
i would say personally for me i was they
just get your
own night wherever you at and host that
night consistently and do
however much time you want to do and
then um
film it and then you know if you feel me
and you got certain
shows that was good you put it out there
and then the comedy clubs will reach out
to you and book you
boom yeah and you're honing that skill
as well you're honing that hosting skill
because like he's saying
with featuring prematurely it is like
you don't want to go on the road and
feature for a club and not do well
because that spreads
you know you only get one first
impression so i would say
great advice yeah hone the skill locally
host host host
that i mean you learn so much from
hosting like my comedy
grew exponentially when i started
hosting my own shows
yes yes and then yeah you can't never
fail in your city because your city
scene you start from the bottom
yeah yeah well it's somebody else city
because like you said that's your first
impression you know
the city you can you can you can take
l's in front of your town
yeah did you host a lot of shows in
oakland yeah
yes um i was hosting a comedy show
uh for about two to three
years um i was hosting a big show with
me and mr fab we was calling this the uh
dope air comedy show
and um we was doing it once a month and
we was bringing big acts uh we bro
uh we brought tony roberts um we brought
michael blackstone red grant
uh who else we bring we brought joe
torre we brought we we brought a good
amount of people who was doing it
every month and the whole city was
coming out because i was popping with
the uh
with my skits and my sketches and my
standard comedy and mr fab is a
a bay area legend so it's like the
collab
was making me like popping that's dope
oh that's dope but a lot of comedians
knew me through
oakland they didn't know me through
hollywood uh-huh but by the time i got
to hollywood they like hey man
like i had a good first impression with
these people so when i was in hollywood
they like
oh this guy he he's like he do his thing
up in in the bay area yeah you're
probably the plug in the bay area it
sounds like
exactly yeah i mean not like burner i
mean like the plug oh yeah
you know what i'm saying but but for
comedy i am the burner of
comments yeah yeah yeah
what a for a comic wanting to start
their own show what kind of tips do you
have
to throw a show to start throwing a show
like something they doing like weekly or
monthly
yeah anything yeah because if they're
like if sean's here and this is like oh
maybe i will
start my own show like where uh where
should he start promote it things like
that
i feel like you should always start a
comedy show where
somewhere you got a good relationship
with some some business so
if you got a uh like restaurants it's
always a good place to
you know do shows because you know a
comedy club and a restaurant is the same
thing you know comedy clubs
rely on their drinks and in the bar you
know
like they food and and they need comedy
so it's like if you
you can start at a restaurant or any
open mic night that's
you know whereas you go to mike now
you'll be like can i have my own light
and they give you a night and just keep
doing it from ground up and promoting it
through people you personally know you
know like
i feel like people will be looking for
stuff that's already
around them yeah how how would you
promote your shows
i i will i will promote my shows through
um of course social media but always
have flyers like i feel like footwork is
still that still matters
like having flyers placing on people
cars passing it to people
having business cards and you know if
you ain't famous or nothing give out
your number just hey what's your number
i'll text you that
you know let anybody have your number
just get the word out there
so and and let people know every friday
you got to have a consistent day
you got to be like every friday every
wednesday something where it stick where
people get bored and be like
i'm not doing that let me just go pull
up on uh john on wednesday because he do
his shows
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah and actually
there's there's a john in this group who
does host the wednesday show that's
pretty funny yeah
luther john did that's dope yeah he he
actually asked a question about social
media
but i do want to tag up uh hosting
hosting is a skill set within itself do
you have any hosting tips for comics
hosting tips uh a good tip
is always you always gotta freestyle i
feel like with hosting
uh your set and jokes all that that
don't that don't really
work a lot it works once you get the the
once you address the room get the energy
of you know uh freestyle a little bit
just get
comfortable up there because the hosts
always gotta break the ice
for the next comedians like if you're
gonna host you can't be selfish you
gotta you gotta host for the next
comedian you're coming out
you know mm-hmm you got to be for the
people so
um that's the tip i i will always you
know give a
tell a host you know host for that night
host for that
room you know yeah that's that's that's
almost what i enjoy
about hosting is like the pressure is
off to really
kill it's literally like setting a fun
vibe and then the
the comedy will come from the vibe but
it's not like about your setup punch
setup punch it is more like setting a
good vibe for the room
yeah yeah and it's always way defined
material you
you would write it's like that's the way
to practice without practicing it
you know it's like that's the way to
practice without going into an open mic
you know or another person's room it's
like let me say this at my show while
i'm hosting
and if it work it i'm gonna continue on
writing and developing that bit but if
it don't work
well i'm just with you all right
i'm bringing up your next
exactly we're just having fun right
everyone
ain't nobody the next funny guy exactly
yeah man yeah it definitely helps you be
more conversational and natural on stage
yeah and this one shifting in
back into social media this is from john
chappelle asking what would you say is
the best social media platform to focus
on i'm pushing instagram and use twitter
for just putting jokes out
how do you grow your following
hmm i i would say i would say um
for standup comedy i would say
instagram and facebook and i would kind
of say facebook
before instagram because facebook got a
more mature audience
and those are type of people like
stand-up comedy it's a age limit you
know you got to be at least
18 and up or 21 and up so um
facebook got that crowd where it's in
between 25 to 55
and that's the audience uh the media
wants because you want people to
actually pay to see you live
yes you know so i would say facebook
first and then
instagram second yeah and do you
are you are you heavy on uh facebook or
did you find momentum like
is instagram your main lane it's kind of
like it's almost like picking one and
being doing good
at one before you try to disperse all
your energy
and i'm not good at any so that's where
my energy is i'm so focused on this
podcast and this facebook group and the
youtube that like
i'm really not active on anything else
but those
those three things but those are strong
audience like youtube yeah those are
hard people you know i'm saying um
facebook
that's a good audience so um in podcast
so
you know that that is a lane where you
don't have to once you got to just find
one social media platform and then they
will follow you on all of them
but um i would say the the
one for me it was instagram
because i was doing the instagram skits
before
instagram got over saturated with the
skits
so like i was doing the instagram skits
when um
it was 15 seconds
i did it with the 15 seconds so the
algorithm and all that it was different
it was easier to get
more attraction at that time but um
i was so heavy on instagram doing the
skits on instagram
i slept on uh youtube and facebook
and what woke me up was i got hacked
i got my instagram hacked on instagram
so i had like 80 000 followers and i
lost my page
and um i had like i probably had like 3
000 followers on facebook
probably had like 10 000 subscribers and
i'm like
if i get hacked again i need all of my
social media platforms be popping so if
i get hacked
i can hit them hit them on facebook like
hey i got hacked on
instagram that's why you can't find me
so exactly that's what made me go
up everything so for all the comedians
out there watching this
um i would recommend if you find
you gotta you gotta be strong on all of
them because you don't want
you don't wanna put all your eggs in one
basket and then you know you should get
your basket get tucked in then it's like
you ain't got no more fruit yeah
exactly and what are you gonna do it's
like it's it's gone it's an app
you know it's like what are you going to
show for it you got a screenshot of what
it used to be
to be like hacked at 80 000 on your blog
you got to chalk it up it's not there
like yeah exactly
yeah if it wasn't for stand-up comedy i
think i would have died then like you
know
exactly st it all comes back i was doing
monthly shows people knew where to find
me so it's like
my instagram page was gone but it's like
i was so
out there with stand-up comedy and doing
so much stuff where it was easy to find
like
you all ma it's that stand up like you i
mean even kevin hart is like
everything else i'm doing i'm still a
stand-up first like it
it's just it's the foundation man it's
the rock of it all
yeah it's i feel like it's that thing
where you know parents
always say like you know you don't know
how i feel to be a parent until you
become one i
i kind of feel like that would stand up
kind of like that's like my first kid
are you gonna be like i don't give a
if i have 20 kids like this is my
kid
yes for sure man it's so beautiful man
and a part of being a stand-up though is
also like that business side
which you you seem to have found a nice
you seem to have good business instincts
in this game as well because it is
show and business so what it what is
like uh that
business hustle of the comedy we hear
about your local
uh upping and the the shows and
producing your own shows and all that
but like on the business side how
how can how can these how can comics
make money in this game man
um i feel like for me personally i
learned more
from comedy i learned more from business
from being around people that's not in
comedy business
so like i learned business from my
my dad my marshawn lynch uh
mr fab um just so many people that's not
like my
my dad always worked for uh
he's worked at nine to five a job and
he's been a manager
so it's like if you're a manager uh uh
at a uh at a on a big corporate level
then you know how to manage
business like you know what i'm saying
so it ain't no difference if you work in
a job if you rap in if you athlete
all of it is business so i learned more
business
from people that's not comedian so i i
would recommend
surrounding yourself around just
business men instead of people that's
just in your field
um a lot of comedians not business man
they're comedians
exactly yeah what what uh what did you
learn from these businessmen
uh i would say
most thing i learned um
they a businessman would teach you is
business first
so i would say the emotions and
the feeling like you're entitled to
things
those people like those four people i
named
and my father number one always say
business is so separate
you know so it's like cuz i'm funnier
than this person don't mean i'm supposed
to get more money than this person
or because um i've been doing it longer
than this person
me now i'm supposed to come out last you
know i'm saying like
stuff like that made me understand the
business like okay like this person
is going last because he sold the most
tickets he's not funnier than me
you know i'm saying uh mr fab was the
first person to tell me
you only got one first impression
you know so it just thinks like that
marshawn lynch was the person that told
me
um if you don't know something find
people
find people that know it you don't
you don't have to be this you're not
supposed to be the smartest
in your camp you know what i'm saying
like
if if you're afraid that you don't know
what this word mean
find somebody that know what that word
mean you know and that's business you
know
and being a comedian comedians always
want to make a joke out of things to
to not look stupid or to to make it look
like they know everything and they're
cool and it's like
the business and got to do with
being funny and being cool
and that's what i learned yeah
yeah and that entitlement is so huge
because we can look at someone on tv and
be like but why not me
but that's out of your control you're
like you know focus on what you can
control
yeah and then i have no i'm saying being
busy savvy because it ain't no
comedy club where i'm from so you know
to get a venue
and to uh to you know count
uh get to set up the chairs and and
pay for the cameraman and all you just
you start doing so much stuff you
i became a businessman and i didn't even
i wasn't even thinking
i was doing that much business mm-hmm
that's how damn near
went to hollywood and realized like oh
all of these is jobs
like i know i'm i mean i'm gonna have
productions and i'm knowing everybody
job because
i hadn't done it you know so it's like
i've
been i've filmed myself i edit my own
videos
i set the chairs up i lighted the
comedians when it was on stage
so i was like by talking about the
hollywood and i'm performing they got a
person that they got a light at the top
of the thing and they just flash
and it's a cameraman and just i get off
the stage and be like y'all can see
the footage and i'm just like this
i'm i don't know how to do all of this
i'm a businessman i'm not a
yes yes that that's what a comedian is
like a swiss army knife and like
it's good to have those other skills of
can you make your own flyers can you add
your own videos like can you
email professionally when you are
emailing a booker like all these
skills that aren't on stage but have a
huge
impact on the stages you end up getting
on exactly like
when mtv reached out to me i didn't have
a manager at the time so
i was talking to mtv myself awesome like
so i know i'm a businessman like i know
i'm a businessman because i can talk to
uh i can i can go to viacom and talk
um yeah you know a lot of comedians
can't do that they just know how to tell
the joke
so i'm like i could be dead ass series
with somebody for an hour and then
perform for hour oh dude i mean that was
like when we interviewed chico bean like
he was i mean he dropped so much game
but he was like
so serious like he was just and i'll get
the same way a lot of people don't even
know i'm a comic until they see me on
stage or like
see me on the internet or something
because like i am more serious and i do
like just to talk
more normally and then you know be funny
for the money type deals so um
yeah there's a switch you know
yeah it's like being an athlete like you
know like um
you know they're not dribbling the ball
after the game like now they gotta
uh talk you know yeah yeah
press conference like and they got
trainers for that and they go to school
for that like they like um they
prepare you for the nba it's not like
you just be in the nba and then you hit
a game winner and then a
person with a mic just come actually
question like they got they got
coaches and people for that so comedy
don't give you no coaches and all that
so if you ain't coming from no
um neighborhood that's gamed up and
teach you certain things you're just
gonna be like
hello you just gonna be joking all day
like dad
you're not supposed to be doing that
yeah and all these skills we're talking
about like his his advice is like
get around people that do have those
skills or listen to interviews of people
that have those skills and start to
learn
just don't try to like figure it out on
your own learn from the people that
already know it
exactly like i watch i watch more
interviews than i watch stand-up comedy
me too yeah i mean like yeah i sit there
and watch the breakfast club
and damon dash and rick ross and kevin
hart and p
diddy i listen like i like how people
like to watch stand-up i like to watch
interviews about people like yes so
that's why like
you know i like i never
met kevin hart you know i'm saying but i
feel like i
really already had to talk with kevin
hart he just ain't hearing my side
but i understood everything he was
saying you know what i'm saying like
like i just i study i study that
more than comedy because i rely on my
natural
ability and i watch comedy is simple you
know you you watch it you study it you
know you learn people
you learn stuff you know the mannerism
the timing of joking punchline but
if you got that you got that you need to
study
the business because they gonna hide
that you can't just
you gotta you gotta look for it it ain't
just gonna pop
up mm-hmm yeah and this is uh this ties
into the uh
business this is a joey rizzuto asking
i noticed you have a separate social
media account for your company do too
much
entertainment um is there a benefit to
separating the two um
yes because you want people to know that
this
is my brand and um
do too much my social media louis belt
is lewis bell that's the the comic
um do too much entertainment that page
i'm the owner of that business but
that's a business page so
that that page is not about me that page
is about comedy that's that page is
about business so
um it's really important because i i
need to
separate the two because um my page is
personal
due to much uh that page is
a brand what what is uh what is your
what is the business what it what made
you want to start it and what are you
doing with it
um the reason i started because i've
been having a business
um for eight years and didn't know it
was a business
you know putting together my own shows
presenting myself
presenting other comedians and um
and um so i i made sure like okay
let me make it to a business so do too
much entertainment that's an llc that's
a legit business
and um it's a comedy brand
and um it's for music too like my
character sunnyvale he make music he rap
so it's like sonny bo is under due too
much
entertainment like he dropped he
releases his music through do too much
entertainment
if you look at the bottom of his music
on apple on
spotify it's going to say do too much
entertainment so it's like
and if you look at louisville comedy
shows and
all the comedy shows i present with
other people is do too much
entertainment presents uh the young og
show
you know so uh that's why it's real
important
to us it that's what i'm doing with it
like
uh do too much entertainment you know is
a
it's a it ain't no difference from a
deaf comedy gym uh russell simmons
presents it it's no different from that
it just got to grow yeah you you seem to
be savvy on the merch game as well and
so many comics
i mean i've been guilty i have this bit
i'm gonna make a shirt about it i'm
about to be a millionaire and now i have
80 shirts in my closet you know what i
mean like
you seem to have been really savvy with
the merch game like um
what kind of tips do you have on
actually creating a successful merch
um the merch is real important because
uh
as a standard comedy as the stand-up
comic
you're always touching people you're
gonna people gonna
uh wanna talk to you at these shows they
wanna meet you so
you gotta always have something to sell
so
um the merch is real important to me
because that was the first
um that was the most money i made
at a period of time in my career because
um
i was under the umbrella of uh mr fab
he was creating his uh dope air store
and
he started out the trunk so he was
telling me like
why are you walking around here famous
and you ain't got nothing to sell
you know so like he gave me that tip and
then
he was like always have something to
sell so i printed out my first shirts
and one day um i just always walked
around my shirts
and uh i went to wingstop one day
and i sold 400 worth of shirts going on
wingstop
and it changed my life i'm like i'm
never not walking around with no merch
um you know so it's like
um that's been heavy on me because i was
making more money with money
i was making more money with merch than
my actual show
oh yeah i've been on tour with that if i
didn't have merch
i wouldn't have come out in positive you
know
exactly so that's why that's always
mandatory for
me are you printing your own merch or do
you have like a plug for that
i got a plug for that i wish i knew how
to do that that's coming soon if you're
a graphic designer and how to print up
your own tap in with me
yes and uh for those of you in the hot
breath verse the plug is the connect
if if anyone didn't know that is the
person who would supply
the printing service i'm sorry
i gotta translate sometimes
i've done i've started comedy in atlanta
i've like
i i was like i just did i was never the
cool kid in the scene so i just went
wherever i could so i'm doing like strip
clubs at 1am
not even thinking like i should be
getting raw i never got robbed though
like it all ended up well but i did some
like shady spots just because that's
where i could get stage time
because some some shows you know you got
to be the cool kid or it's like do you
have a beard and a flannel shirt no
well then you're not ironic enough for
this shirt that's why you didn't get
robbed
yeah because that i feel like that's the
reason why
because i'm coming in here with the
perception i'm the cool kid
yeah they you know it's easier for you
you know that's why gentrify like
gentrification is happening like
these people that's moving to these
neighborhoods they're not getting
rockets they don't look like a threat
but if i walk around the hood that i'm
not from i look like
what you doing you know what i'm saying
like i'm disrespecting they hood yeah
yeah
so dude this has been awesome um i mean
just to kind of
land the plane here do you do you have
any like
closing advice for comics or any like
favorite advice you've gotten i know
you've been able to
work with mike epps who you met when you
were 10 years old and now you've gotten
to actually work with them and even this
special
was a part of the project with him like
i mean is there any advice
this part this project would have
nothing to do with him oh but he was one
of the comics on it
no i'm on i'm on my own special oh but i
mean the
like i meant like the the boogie cousins
presents he's presented
a bunch of different kind like gary owen
carlos miller like
it's a bunch of different right yeah no
demarcus cousin boogie comedy slam
presented
those comedians mike f's are just one of
those comedians one of those comedians
yeah yeah yeah i'm just saying it's cool
to be like you're having a special
alongside with like mike epps doing one
that's what i'm saying
yeah that's you yeah that's huge
um like some advice i would give a
comedian yeah
it's mandatory like it sounds so like
like you know
cliche but it's like you really gotta
find your own lane
and it's like uh you know as a comedian
you get inspired by
certain comedians or uh certain things
and it's like that's not going to help
you you got to help yourself
like comedy unfortunately is really like
a self-made job it's like you up there
alone
and i'm not saying it's going you're
gonna go in the game alone but
kinda so like you might wanna collab
with people
work with people that's next to you stop
worrying about the people that's ahead
of you
you know what i'm saying so it's like
because you at the open mic don't mean
you doing bad because
you um you got a special amazon don't
mean you less of a comedian because they
things on netflix and you know because
you got a special netflix don't mean
you're gonna be rich forever
you know like it just
it's it's levels to comedy and always
appreciate the level you own and always
reach
always you know try to get to the next
level but you know take it step by step
yes step by step and i loved your
mentality even in hearing your interview
on comedy hype about like
i did a shorter special because i want
to put out a dope
20 as opposed to like a mediocre 45.
like i want
my first special to be something people
are like you
first impression again like you said you
want that first impression to hit him in
the face and not be like
well the first 20 was cool but then he
kind of rambled you know that's great
self-awareness that a lot of comics egos
would normally get in the way of
so i commend you for that mindset man
that's that's what's going to go far
and that's just business you know what
i'm called i know i know how to do 45
minutes you know what i'm saying but
i got 45 minutes for certain city i'm
catering to the whole world
yeah man so savvy yeah
and when you booked your bigger names on
your shows this one's coming in at the
buzzer
how would you book a bigger name with a
lower budget
how would i book a bigger name for a
uh take a pay cut you have to uh
sacrifice some money for yourself and
others to make
that uh headliner um you know to reach
his budget
uh budget and and if you don't have
a budget where you know you can't get a
a headlining comedian
you don't got the money relationships
you know
if you got a good relationship people
sometimes people do stuff for free
and a favor for you because they believe
in you and that's something that
um is priceless that's when your talent
kicking you know
talent can get you things that money
can't buy
you know so sometimes you know you
performing at a
a certain night you do so good and you
know sometimes you ask that favor it can
come through for you
boom boom well man we appreciate you
coming through here
it's it's so exciting to catch you at
this point in your career man and i'm
excited to have you back on here
when you're even at another level and
we're all just going to keep growing
together here
so now this show is dope i've never been
on a show like this this is like really
like
for comedy like this is a stand-up
comedy show for sure you know this is
dope nobody i didn't done a lot of stuff
nobody's doing what you're doing so i
salute you two for that
and um you own something you don't even
need nobody to to do what you're doing
that's another tip
that committee's got to learn find
something you can do no matter what
and that's what you're doing you're
going to do this
until you to you're dead and gone you
can keep doing this
my man well i appreciate you saying that
dude that that makes my heart smile
yeah we're like rap radar for uh comedy
here
yeah this is this is very inspiring for
sure wow
well um the the last thing we comics do
on here would you mind um looking at the
camera saying your name
and uh why comics should listen to hot
breath
oh man it's your boy lewis belt and uh
if you're a comedian
you need to listen to hot breath because
you need to get this game you need to
get this knowledge that you can't get in
college you know what i'm saying
tune in tap in boom
my man and uh where where can we tap
into uh your special please promote
everything you have going on with the
hot breath verse we want to support you
okay so off the dribble you can follow
me on social media lou do too much on
all
platforms uh make sure you tune in to my
comedy special it's boogie comedy slam
rookie a year
on amazon prime it's out right now um
20 minutes short short and sweet and uh
it's only five dollars to buy so make
sure you buy it support it and leave a
review put a comment on
amazon primary review and uh tell me
what you think
my man yes and uh everyone watching this
or if you're watching us on youtube
later listening to this on the podcast
these q a's we do exclusively in our
facebook group so if you want to get
involved
in that go into the link in the show
description you'll see a link to join
along with the links to all of the
projects lewis has going on with his
social media
and this special i watched it before the
interview it is well worth
your money this is without a doubt one
of comedy's future stars so we're so
excited to have him on here so
show him the support that you guys show
hot breath
and uh lewis belt it's uh it's been a
privilege my friend thanks for coming on
hop right
man it's the honor we're gonna do it
again my man all right hot breath verse
we'll see you next time